the signee ADA numerous piranhas summer
do Orem pre moorim sigh how to enshrine
ganske this is Tara grammar one get
asked it ish Purcell burnished
demonstrator and con that means that a
given number is the sum of two primes I
hold it for a completely certain result
I'm looking aside from the fact that I
can't myself prove it so we're talking
about Goldbach's conjecture one of the
real old chestnuts of mathematics
Christian Goldbach was born in 1690 in
clinic spring now part of Russia and he
was a fairly serious mathematician but
his great moment of Fame came in a
correspondence with Leonard Euler who
was really one of the great
mathematicians of all time and in a
letter that he wrote to Euler on the 7th
of June in 1742 in that letter Goldbach
proposed this conjecture which is God
sort of ironed out after a few rounds
but it is the famous conjecture Nell
which says that every even integer is
the sum of two prime numbers why even
integers of prime numbers are mostly odd
numbers and if you add two odd numbers
you always get an either number that's
like a picture that shows how this
happens I'm going to write two lines
they'll both have the primes on them
three and let's see four is not a prime
5 is a prime 6 is not a prime seven is a
prime eight nine 10 I'm not primes and
11 is a prime let's put it too and just
a please pretty because 2 is a prime why
should we discriminate against 2 so here
I'll put 2 on the other side as well 2
is a prime 3 is a prime 4 is still not a
problem 5 and we could go on so this is
an infinite game and now let's draw
lines that connect the side so I'm going
to try my best to draw a line parallel
to the lines
drawn in Evin now let's look where these
lines intersect and write down the sums
of the two prime that are coming through
here's four that's the two plus two
three plus two is five well that's not
even but we'll put it down anyway just
for the sake of having something there
and of course we have seven and nine now
three plus three is the first
interesting one here's six and then
let's see what else do we have we have 5
plus 3 is 8 and 7 plus 3 is 10 and 11
plus 3 is 14 that's a bit of a skip it
might be worried about that one in 13
plus 3 and 16 remains across we just fix
12 we've skipped 12 do we get at 12 well
yes of course we do we get 5 plus 7 is
12 and here's 7 plus 5 s and other 12
this is a symmetric picture so it's not
too surprising when we get the same
thing both ways seven and seven we saw
114 before this is a really different 14
we had 3 plus 11 or 7 plus 7 what's this
one 11 + 5 another 16 years 5 plus 11 is
another 16 and then here is 5 plus 13 is
18 and 7 plus 11 another 18 really
different 18 I have 13 plus 720 here's
11 and 11 22 and you can see as it goes
down I sort of fill things out now what
you don't see from this picture so well
is that actually as the numbers get big
there are really a lot of ways of
writing your numbers and sum of two
primes and in fact you can estimate how
many in a very crude simple-minded way
and it turns out to me that you're
really pretty close for big numbers so
let's let's do a little calculation one
of the most famous theorems in number
theory is the prime number theorem and
it says that the density of the primes
are
on n so the chance of a number near and
being prime is n divided by the natural
logarithm event that's the prime number
theorem I'm not going to try to prove it
and justify it but it's true so using
that we can estimate the number of ways
to write a given number in our to N
let's say as the sum of two primes let's
use a different number to M so how many
ways and you write 2 times M that's an
even number as P plus Q where P and Q
are prime
that seems pretty mysterious they just
if you don't know anything about it but
it's easy to analyze so if you write to
embers of some people's cube then one of
P and Q had better be bigger than m and
yet what be given Rico and the other one
will be less than or equal to M if we
look at a particular number in it's a
little bigger than between m and 2m its
chance of being prime is 1 over the law
now logarithm doesn't change very fast
very slowly growing function so we can
estimate it as being the log of M so if
I write if I write to M as a plus B
where a is bigger than or equal to M and
B is less than or equal to gamma then
the chance of a being prime is about 1
over the log of M so the chance the
probability today will just by accident
be prime is about equal to 1 over the
log of I am okay and that's the same for
the chance of B being prom it's about 1
over log of M so the chance of both of
them being prime at the same time is one
of the log of M Squared well that's a
bit of a fib it would be 1 over log M
Squared if they were independent events
but it's not quite independent we'll
discuss will talk about that in a minute
how many chances do we get to compute
this probability we had to choose an a
between m and 2 m so there are m choices
a number of ways to write to M as P plus
Q is about equal to M divided 2 the log
of M Squared M is a whole lot bigger
than the log of M I think of base 10
think M is a million and the log of M is
6 so you know this is like a million
over 36 and if it's a billion or a 10 to
the 12th let's say then M would be 10 to
the 12th and this would be 12 so 10 to
the 12th over 144 in other words this is
this is pretty close to him actually so
it's an enormous lis large number so for
any given large number there are going
to be lots of ways of writing it as a
sum of two puns
somebody I was talking to said maybe
that's why it's so hard to prove if they
were a unique way then maybe you could
just find it you could figure out the
formula for it but if they're just any
old ways almost everything works then
how are you going to find that needle in
a haystack or the haystack around the
needle rather this is very heuristic
right we didn't prove anything in this
little discussion we just made a guess
but it turns out to be a very good guess
and there people have tabulated these
things there's something called goldbox
comment which reach number M you show
the number of ways of writing it is with
some two primes and it grows just as you
would expect like this you see this
wonderful picture there's some variation
of course some numbers have lots of ways
some a few but even the ones with the
fewest ways the number seems to grow
printing steadily do you ever get a
really really big even number that has
like any one way or what no one has ever
found such a thing I think it really
just keeps going I don't know if there's
any lower bound known or guessed
so it remained unproven all this time
people have proven other things people
have made other conjectures around it
for example Harold Health got friendly
in 2013 managed to prove that every odd
number is the sum of three products and
that actually implies that every even
number bigger than something is the sum
of four primes so you know that
something and Hardy and Littlewood
famous famous number theorist decided
that it was too bad to leave out the odd
numbers so sum of three times that's all
very well but let's make it more special
how about the sum of a prime and twice a
prime so the sum of three problems would
take two of them to be equal so they
conject it as that was true nobody can
prove that either but all these things
seem very likely to be true my friends
were and like number theorists who would
die to prove Goldbach's conjecture it
really is would be a great prize a great
coup you know the professionals are
showing about them if I talk to you
about good luck you might think I might
be working on it you might think I'm
nuts but because nobody really has a
clue how to attack it I think but
nevertheless people do work on it and
sometimes in their closet sometimes in
their attics I'm sure lots of my friends
would love to prove it so secretly I
swear I've never wake them go back to
the chase
honest-to-god 22.4 284 to 23 sauce a lot
of information and then one more thing
one more thing to you we can learn from
this a prime number formula the nth
prime twiddles or is approximately n
lots of